leadership
thank you
actually Madam chair if we could do 274
first I think it would be easier
258 was scheduled for summer oh well
that's why I
I have coffees
or the social media members
he did not come out
the line by line objections that were
oh
okay and Madam chair here's a here's one
copy of
uh
comments and concerns
okay yeah that's
Mr Morrill gave me a copy of that I'll
so
um I move
yeah all right you may speak to your
motion well as you can tell by the
second is there a second
uh as you can tell by the comments there
are a large number of issues with House
Bill 274
and we don't really have time to address
them
I think we can do some more work on this
over the summer and
look at the issues that are raised and
the concerns of the agencies and see if
we come up with something
and but we don't we don't have the time
to do it right now
I think that some of the concepts from
House Bill 274 can be included in house
bill 358.
not all of them but some of them and
that will help to
um
for example I think we I the aid the
rulemaking agency excuse me the
administrative rules is now sending the
rulemaking register for every
representative which takes care of the
questions that were raised on 358 about
notifying the subject commit subject
experts everybody gets it whether
they're a sponsor or just just care
about the issue they'll have the
information and they can act on it and I
think that solves one of the concerns
and I was amazed that I don't remember
who it was that suggested it but it's so
easy to do that I'm amazed we didn't do
it sooner
[Laughter]
you seconded would you care to
um
and I will say that
my own opinion is that this should
actually just be killed it's got so many
problems and as the motion made
suggested uh these issues could be
addressed in 358. so
but not all of them and I know the
sponsors are very concerned about some
of the issues that have been raised I
think that retaining it
having a couple of months of people
getting the rulemaking register we can
see how much interest there is among the
legislature
in a very small amount
but still we can Implement a few of the
ideas right away and see if
there's any anything else that needs to
do
all right I'm not sure if there's an
appetite to implement too many of these
things
um my what I kind of thought of after
the hearing was
we heard from so many state agencies
with objections and I I'm not sure that
all the state agencies are even aware of
this and I suspect if they're made aware
of it and we're studying it over the
summer we're going to hear a lot more
I think we may be cutting in for a lot
of work on it
all right well we'll see what happens
but I looking at the people who are the
sponsors I think it would be um
representative Schmidt thank you madam
chair so uh I I am in accord with
representative McGuire's suggestions uh
I think one of the important things that
could be done
um by uh a working group uh working on
some of the issues is to clarify the
fact that a lot of the concerns that the
bill uh seeks to address
uh our misunderstandings either of the
Constitution of the gel car process
especially or uh I don't know the law of
gravity for that matter uh because uh
there there are just a lot of things in
the bill that either don't work
shouldn't work or can't work uh so uh to
the degree that we get that out there
because the people who who are behind
this more than just putting their name
on something because they think it's
going to
solve the problems of the administrative
rule process
are uh it's kind of a pro former
sponsorship uh in some respects uh but
if the people had any experience of gel
car
then other than representative McGuire
uh they they would know that some of
this stuff is I say either unworkable
and necessary or unconstitutional so and
it's important for the legislature to
understand the gel car process better
because it's clear they don't I mean
having served on jail card for the past
16 plus years I know that we almost
never
see a rep
at a jail car meeting
I mean we as you know I've seen a couple
uh over the years but almost never and
most people have no idea what gel car
does so the the information and
educational aspects of uh of a retain
bill could serve that purpose for the
for anybody who's willing to subject
themselves to some education
thank you
I I will say that I think
um possibly sending out
questions about the rules May
solicit a little more interest from
members I think a lot of our members
don't understand
jalcar and therefore just kind of avoid
the whole issue yes as
when we were getting ready to sign this
off the speaker the speaker and I were
talking about it and he intends to have
the Committees get
the rep have a subset a subcommittee on
each
legislative policy committee and charge
them with looking at rules and so that
at least some members of the legislature
will be more informed other than Edna of
course were all experts
and so that way we'll we'll give them a
chance to look at the rules
well I think in addition that the um the
reality is that most legislators don't
understand rules
they they don't they don't get it what
rules do uh we've had people come in and
and lecture us on how the agencies are
running wild running among their out of
control blah blah blah blah and so forth
as if uh as if there were no
requirements uh whatsoever so the other
thing that we might be able to do if we
retain this is take a look at the places
where there is still broad rulemaking
Authority which is why the agencies can
run amok because we've said you guys
make the rules we don't want to know
about it
well that that's not that that is not
unfounded uh and and it such a remark is
indicative of the fact that you actually
know what you're talking about because
you've been on the job car for what 10
years now anyway
15 okay who's counting uh
uh
and and the thing is that uh
that
the reality is uh that
um most of people uh you remember the
bill that you filed early days when you
came on Edna uh to uh repeal a whole
remember the one repealed like 30
sections anybody still here Mike would
be knowledgeable about that uh
whole slate it must have been 30 repeal
uh sections to the rule and a bunch of
them dealt with these these barn doors
as you came to call them uh and it's
true and the the first statement in the
statute would be the commissioner shell
right rules to implement the statute
well duh that means that he or she can
do anything that's necessary but as we
also learned of a number of the rules
writing coordinators that the agencies
really don't like that because uh it was
a lack of specificity means they're
completely out there on the diving board
uh with some questions whether they're
in water in the pool uh and when the
when the statute says you shall do this
and this and this and this and this then
they're only carrying out the
legislature's instructions totally
different set of circumstances and a
different outcome as well but to the
degree that you repeal one of these barn
doors
upon which a whole entity has been
constructed in many cases I think the
Medicare rules were one of the examples
something which the commissioner wrote
had broad rule making Authority
um and the net effect was that if you
repealed that Authority the whole entity
would collapse because there was no
Authority for it except that particular
thing not a good arrangement and we have
since and representative McGuire has led
the fight and I've supported her because
it really is true that it's much more
effective if we say exactly what the
what the agencies should do and not
leave them out there to have to invent
everything not a good situation and we
don't we don't write those
broad rule-making authorities anymore
because of the exact issue that we're
discussing
um I just want to acknowledge I I see Mr
Williams from helping Human Services uh
who was here they did not have a
representative at our hearing I believe
I'm sure they have the same issues as
the other agencies pretty much although
yes I did have a conversation with him
before we began and he indicated that so
like I said I just wanted to acknowledge
that he appeared to
put in a word for for that agency today
um so are we ready to vote on this I
think
um I'll just ask for a show of hands
um
is everyone okay with retain
those of you may be wondering why my
hand did not appear I am not on the
I thank you all from the agency
this morning we we appreciate your input
as to the difficulties with the bill and
and your time and as a long-term member
of calc one moment Mr commissioner
uh um if you may the thing is it's very
important that we have you people here
people who actually work with this and
are governed by it and so forth who know
what works and what doesn't and Mr
morrill's memo is extremely useful and
to the point so thank you all of you
foreign
all right so the subcommittee on
houseville 274 is closed
and I will open the subcommittee on
and
I did um
representative McGuire did you have an
the things that I thought we should
change is on page one the the
starting on line 23
the description set that revised text
needs to be Rewritten we want we want to
and have in fact begun
sending the notice with the copy of the
rule to every member of the legislature
which is
um
easier than this to be honest it just
put a
it's an email list
and it's more effective because there
are often legislators who are not on the
policy committee who might be interested
in a bill
yeah it might be subject matter experts
or the sponsor or whatever so just send
it to everybody
and
this should allow the legislature to
look at the rule and comment during the
public comment period
and I will say that they take
comments from legislators whether
they're the sponsors or on the policy
committee or not very seriously I had a
chat with
uh representative not representative
with mismo digliani on the
vehicle registration rules which I had
some constituent issues with
and they replied and looked and they
made some changes I'm not 100 happy with
their changes but until I get another
constituent
issue I'm going to at which point I'll
ask them to take another look at it but
they did you know acknowledge the
comments and
um consider them
so any legislator can comment
and this will be
no more work for the agencies unless
they get a lot of legislators writing
NASA emails saying you've got it wrong
in which case I'll have to start over
again but if it's just the usual
specific comments
this is during the public comment period
anyway they're expecting comments
so it's it should be efficient enough
for the agency to deal with legislative
comments at that point
much easier than at any other point and
more appropriately than when it comes to
jailcar
so that section would be Rewritten to
just say so
I agree that that is that the time for
comments is early days not after things
have already taken the right turn or
left her well I mean obviously the
agency can go out for comments before
they have a draft
but
probably easier for people who are not
complete experts to look at them after
I would ask Mr Morrill would do you have
thank you
representative Ryan would would you guys
turn your mics off because I think we're
getting a little overloaded
yeah all right and then um I sent you
comments that I
yes representative O'Brien
thank you madam chair Madam chair may I
ask a question uh to uh representative
McGuire through the chair please uh I
hate to bring up 274 we put that one to
bed temporarily for now
um but I'm looking on page four and
where it refers to uh notifying some of
the stakeholders by U.S mail I see in
and it's my hope that this would Trump
uh in the future work as we look at 274
uh
and get away from the U.S Meal which I
imagine would be a cost to uh to state
to send it out to all the stakeholders
okay it's on pay uh House Bill 274 page
yes
with envisioning setting it up by email
I'm I'm I just add there's already an
existing email list for the rulemaking
register and I believe they just added
all house members or possibly all
Republicans all Democrats
okay so it wouldn't really go out U.S
mail snail mail
okay I wouldn't think that would be
timely and would Dad if if I may follow
up
uh what dad also include some of the
stakeholders themselves or is this uh
entirely meant just for the
representatives the stakeholders are
this is for the rulemaking register
which comments which lists all the rules
that are being
that are now in draft form and going to
have a public hearing the
these stakeholders are determined by
each agency and they send out each
specific rule for example a licensing
board sends a notice to all of the
licensees
I don't know who Des sends licenses
sends their notices to but I bet they
have a mail-in list of people that want
to know
and
for example hopefully when their schools
are coming up for a specific weapons
they do
send out drafts even someone's prior to
often file to them they'll get them
before we move forward if not they'll
they get copies now
one smile
thank you
[Music]
right
Michael Morrell director of the
administrative rules unit in office of
legislative Services I do know for a
fact that the Department of
Environmental Services always involves
stakeholders because they want to be up
front and it saves problems later on
they automatically send things to the US
EPA and depending on the type of rule
whether it's regulating Wetlands or
something they know who the major
stakeholders are and they involve them
also when agencies send submit notices
for the rulemaking register they are
also obliged by law to notify any member
of the public who has asked them to be
notified of rules on a particular
subject
combination I think now it's uh email
that provision about U.S males been in
there a long time and it's not practical
to do that that used to be a burden for
agencies because if say the nursing
board had to send out notices to all 30
000 nurses then it would be very
expensive
was one of my concerns when I was going
through this field because it didn't
really make it clear how the
notification was happening and my
thought was yeah if you've got to notify
a lot of people via U.S mail several
times a year you're talking some pretty
large dollar signs so I think we have to
be really careful about mandating in
statute that stuff be by US mail because
then you're stuck with it so we ought to
Tinker with that to make sure that
notification is accomplished but but
it's but it U.S mail in some cases I
think U.S mail makes sense because then
you have a legal record just like
um at the county level notification has
to be in the newspaper for example by by
Statute and so some of these things we
are necessary but the the thing that Mr
moral attorney moral just uh is stated
is a factor that we have to take into
consideration so we just have have a
little box that we we make sure that we
get that straightened out which way
we're going to do it and and not
burden the statute and the agencies with
the U.S mail requirement where it's not
appropriate
well I will be I'll check the language
with director moral but my intent is to
use email for the rulemaking register
perfectly adequate for reaching 99 of
the actually more I believe represent
Mr moral I believe you've indicated you
have another comment yes as the statute
is written now it just sets up options
as far as a type of notification for the
agency so they might send things by US
mail they might post something on their
website I believe House Bill 358 is
going to require all agencies to post a
copy of their proposed rule on their
website
major major agencies do that now but I
another section that I would like to
include is that
when the agency
prepares the final rule after the public
comment period
they should acknowledge and respond to
the public comments
the department of Ed of Environmental
Services does so very nicely right now
other agencies may or may not
and I think that having an explicit
record
that yes we got these comments and this
is what we did with them they may say we
thought these were irrelevant and we
ignored them
but at least we'll know that the public
has commented and the agency has at
least looked at the comments and I'm not
quite sure where in two set in 358 to
put that requirement
um I would ask the sponsor
um she's a member of the committee
um do you
do you feel that you can have an
amendment ready if subcommittee meets
again or would you prefer retaining this
to have a little life I prefer to have a
set I'd prefer to have it have it passed
was it because I'd like to
um so I guess I will get work on an
agency
well since it's not an early Bill we
have several weeks yeah so
um if you will let us know when you're
ready and we can schedule another
subcommittee meeting
I will add respond to comments because
that I think that at least is
will help a lot because there's nothing
worse than writing a comment on a rule
and having it vanished Into The Ether at
least if the agency when they come back
with the final rule you'll know that
they looked at your comment and said
well this person doesn't know what she's
talking about
or we've con we've considered it and
don't want to do it or we considered it
a nice idea we've Incorporated and we
yeah it sounds reasonable
any further comments Mr Morrill
I was going to suggest to representative
McGuire one further Amendment to the
bill our office recently discovered an
error in 541a
we should have found it much earlier in
2021 RSA 541
A14 was changed in two places to require
that the gel car respond to a final
proposal by agencies within 60 days it
had been 45 days and it was changed to
60 days unfortunately there's a
provision in 542 and a 13 that was not
changed and still says 45 days I think
all right so
um
that that's all the comments
from the from the hearing and that other
people have brought to my attention uh
it does include
358 as written does include
some of the
scheduling fixes from 274 like on page
four it says in the case of a board of
commission the deadline is 14 days after
its regular meeting
so that we don't want to require the
boards or commissions to have to
schedule special meetings to deal with
rulemaking
event
um
I
Madam chair I had a question
sorry I'll yield thank you
I'm just wondering
so when you go when you once you get the
amendment and we look at this that's
when the committee will look at 274 and
see what's already covered here
[Music]
right
so
what exactly just March 8th and it
should be ready
so my question is I heard conversation
and this is a process thing forgive me
being new
um
274 I heard comments that it probably
has some things that are covered in 358.
so my question is by dealing with 358
and moving it along then when we look at
two
the other one
274. uh we will be able to study then
what's already covered in 358 that could
be removed from 274 my understanding
thank you
my dyslexic brain was trying to
reconcile all those comments so thank
you
retained bills are not worked on till
we're through with all the house bills
and all the Senate bills so you're
I try to schedule one meeting in May or
early June to scope up what you're going
to do on the bill
and then we get back together in late
thank you madam chairs it's just uh
scheduling issue uh sounds like we have
mutual agreement on the McGuire
amendment that will be forthcoming I
just want to can that be scheduled I
think the uh the committee chair did say
March 8th is that something we can do
right before the executive session you
know have a brief uh
subcommittee meeting and then get right
into executive session although I do
like coming up here
you'll be coming up on the 8th for sure
foreign